how do you silence distraction no matter
how important to achieve your number one
priority hmm on top when I was still a
sniper I actually had a much easier time
of this I'm I'm I'm a DD in a lot of
ways and whatever I want to focus on a
TD doesn't mean that you can't focus on
stuff it just means like when the
teacher tells you to focus on something
you're busy doing other stuff and so
right it's not a deficit disorder it's
that I don't give a shit what you're
trying to show me but that right there
that's what I want to look at so I I had
a way of just I would like if I had to
watch a crossroad I watched that
crossroad was my whole world and it
wouldn't matter what was now don't
doesn't mean I was a situationally aware
but I would watch that crossroad like my
my life depended on it
are somebody's life depended on it which
which fat a lot of times it did and if I
have a nut I found actually and this is
one of the reasons why I'm starting to
meditate again I'm seeing a therapist
again I'm listening to
Jaco podcasts and reading extreme
ownership no I'm being serious is that I
preach in my civilian post military post
wounded post addiction phase world I've
I've lost a little bit of my ability to
push out the input I don't want I have a
hard use to read a book a month at the
at the minimum and I'm gonna talking
like I'm talking like a book you know
that I showed you I had to 33 laws of
war mm-hmm in my suitcase I've been
reading that for three months and I'm
maybe half done I have a real hard time
now achieving that that zone of
distraction and I'm trying to get it
back because it's really I get a lot
done you know I have I have my my
politics I have the book I do keynote
speeches I have my kids I have all my
hobbies you know I'm trying to support
veterans support charities that support
veterans and and I still get a lot done
but I could get so much more done if I
could turn off some things in my mind
sometimes and I don't know what what's
happened or what if this is what an
addicts brain is like now or if it's
just I'm always seeking something I get
bored easily that's part of the EDD I've
always had that but when I found
something and latched on to it I used to
be like just I was 100% focused until I
became you know I got as much of that as
I could and then I would move on to the
next thing and yeah I got to be honest
I've visualization though going back to
the first question is one way that you
can do it and I've started meditating to
get my mind back into that state I used
to do a lot of yoga and I used to do a
lot of mindfulness not training I don't
know what people could now it's called
mindfulness training back then I think
it was just called reflection or
something
I call it jiu-jitsu yeah well when I'm
done the bodybuilding show in November I
will start jiu-jitsu oh you you might
actually be starting to Jitsu tomorrow
just don't hurt me everyone I know who
starts jiu-jitsu hurts something that's
why I'm holding off but and I would I
will definitely come let you ragdoll me
but my point is that I've lost it and
I'm probably the last guy to give you
advice right now on how to lock out the
world because I have to put on
headphones and crank music to get
through a workout right now and I know
this I didn't know I'm detrimental in it
and I and I and I'm aware of it and I'm
trying to correct it
and it bugs the shit out of me it really
does it makes me feel like less of a
person so let me tell you about a
transition that I went through yes first
of all before the war I then military
sent me to college so I had to go to
college and I as I said earlier as I
said before I was super focused when I
went to college I've been in the SEAL
Teams for ten years I was a go-getter I
was a hard charger I was like oh you
want me to read this book boom I would
sit down and just force myself to read
it and then got back to the SEAL Teams
and like like when I went to college I
literally read every single thing that I
was assigned and nobody does that in
college nobody does that
I read every single page of every single
thing I was assigned during college
that's a ridiculous it's almost a waste
of time
it's almost embarrassing EKKO definitely
thinks it's a waste of time
but but it was because I just could just
go lock my brain down and get it done
and then get back to the teams and the
teams officer in the teams you have a
lot of administrative work to do
evaluations and after-action reports and
all these things and I would do the same
thing I just go on a lockdown mode and I
put my brain on it and boom I'd go
through it and just get it done I would
just be able to focus so like each thing
laser focus laser focus that report done
god be gone report done okay okay so I
go to Iraq the first time no big deal
I go to Iraq the second time did you
know it's a much tougher deployment it's
guys are getting wounded guys my guys
are getting killed and I come home and I
get put into running the training and
with running the training all of a
sudden the others administrative
requirements there was administrative
requirements overseas as well and you
know what we did lock them down and god
I'm done I get home and I remember the
first time I got to do
I think it's evaluations which in the
military and the Navy anyways doing
evaluations is a real pain it's a real
pink administrative administration of
our values all the truth yeah at this
place I was at huge running training at
a hundred guys and every one of them is
like a little mini term paper or
something it has to be perfect right
it's in a person's military record
forever they're really stressful about
it
and I used to have no problem just to
hammer on those things out so I get back
from that deployment and I'm sitting
down and you know I start doing I'm like
this is stupid
this doesn't matter I don't know why I'm
doing this right well how do I have to
do that kind of sort of dude saying the
same things that I would always brag on
people for saying like this is stupid oh
now your men are stupid you don't want
to fill out the report and take care of
your guys you don't know good write a
good evaluate your career is yeah isn't
worth your 5 no surprises okay you know
so I said I heard myself saying this
right and what what the constant
undertone of all this was that this
stuff doesn't matter combat was what
mattered and and when you get back from
that situation where man your buddies
are getting killed you're getting
wounded your friends are getting wounded
this piece of paper it doesn't matter
and you say to yourself I don't care
about this and at some point and it
didn't took me maybe 2 or 3 months I did
what I had to do to get by but as I sit
there and I looked at myself and I said
you know what the combat doesn't matter
anymore you're not in it you're not in
it right now this is now what matters
your mind was still there my mind was
still there thinking that that was all
that matters and like I said on the last
podcast actually it's in the past and it
doesn't matter anymore so you know what
you have to do you have to be a man and
you have to do your job now and this is
what matters now and that to me made a
big transition for me and it you know I
haven't even thought about this until
until you were talking about it because
I remember what it was like to to go
from when I went to college and when I
was before I deployed remaining I would
just be so laser focused Beauty able to
just burn through things and then when I
got back and it was not there and it was
all because I thought all this stuff
doesn't matter this doesn't matter it
doesn't matter
what matters you know there's guys
getting killed overseas right now that's
what matters and I had to say you know
what no that stuff doesn't matter right
now and you know and also I was in
charge of training and I said what
matters is doing this getting guys
trained to go overseas and I became
obsessed with that and slightly
psychotic about getting guys ready for
combat I mean I was preparing them for
what they were very go into for what
they were going into and you know you
could I'm sure there were many seals
that went through the training that I
was overall in charge of and would
attest to the fact that I was probably
pretty borderline psychopathic at that
point but I think that's a long run in
my training no offense dude but I want a
psycho running my combat training up so
I thought what go ahead
okay you were just gonna say you think I
think that telling yourself and
recognizing to yourself why are you
trying to do this thing because you're
trying to do something because it does
matter right it has to matter in some
way even if it's just filling out the
paperwork to get your license from the
DMV and all that doesn't matter
oh actually no what it does matter
you're gonna get arrested if you get
probably you know it's like no it does
matter these little things these little
stupid meaningless tasks in life they
actually do matter so you know what you
do you line them up and you freaking
crush them that's what you do that's
what you do you line up these stupid
meaningless things and you crush them
and you use them as an exercise in
discipline they become an exercise in
just one oh this thing doesn't matter
guess what I'm going to crush it now
bring it to me where's my DMV form watch
me fill this out that's what I'm gonna
do so maybe I turn like some little
meaningless things into a personal
competition of discipline but me how its
how consistent are you making that
happen though I mean let me tell you
so for it for instance since we started
the podcast I I have to read you know
basically a book a week and then at once
I read it I've got to go back into it
yeah you do like a book report and and
go back through it and say and how is
this gonna flow together what part so
I'm spending a lot of time on that right
now and I've been able to do it every
time so far
um so I think because I've lost my
ability to be consistent and that's what
that's what's really bumming me out like
when I when I your book isn't
I mean it's thick but I should have been
able to read this in two or three solid
days of read yes I told you how
successful I was yes not very and that
bugs the shit at him and it's a it's a
it's a it's a fail it's a it's a you
know what though I think this is a
failure in my part I I think that this
is the same thing when we were talking
about on the last podcast and I think
echo said when you say oh you know what
I'm not gonna finish this book right now
it's it I don't really want to it's sort
of like when you say oh I'm not gonna
quit I said I don't want to though
that's what I'm saying
you say but I don't want to do it right
now I can push it off a little bit you
accept that do you accept that answer
hmm you accept that answer the soldier
Jody right wouldn't accept that answer
would not do you self-talk not really
not really I'm not a guy that says you
know I'm gonna do this I'm gonna do that
I just do it right I just go and do
whatever that thing is
I think cuz you you kind of have become
that so it's more of like I mean put
kind of crudely that's habitual for you
to just do it you know remember how and
it was I think it was kind of funny
where I used this example like how you
said you use it as an exercise of
discipline so I I said this example one
time where I was in line at the grocery
store and I had a 12-pack of beer do we
have to relive this now and I was
standing in line there's maybe three
four people in front of me so I'm like
alright it's gonna be a while for me to
get up there this beer is giving you
decided you're gonna hold the beer
that's right I remember this story yeah
so exactly right but it wasn't that okay
and the reason I decided to hold the
beer it wasn't because that benefited me
right then it it was an exercise in
mental but here's the create okay we're
getting we're way off the question but
physical tasks sure no problem
yeah
because it's it's visceral it's real I
can feel it but to sit down and and and
read the report on the sewer charges
that are gonna be coming in on the tax
report for the city next year
what song what's going on on Twitter
yeah it all they kind of the same thing
though really exactly but I'm wondering
I'm wondering if my brain hasn't
replaced the oxycotin with social media
yeah like I had to quit drinking because
okay we are way off the thing but the
the hardcover came out last September
and the hardcover unflinching the making
of a Canadian sniper by Jodi midok
printed by Simon & Schuster available on
Amazon through Jocko store.com click the
link to Amazon but you know okay yeah so
I already said I already said I already
said it so anyway the hardcover came out
drinking I drank every day from the day
it came out that so we had four hundred
and fifty people at the event Kevin
Newman my buddy who's a he's a
well-known news anchor in Canada doesn't
interview with me on the stage and we
got standing ovations we go oh we
celebrate me the president of the
company my editor we have a good good
night the next day if I only doesn't
have one drink I was having 10 and that
went from September to the new year yeah
and I was hit fat and I you know I was
sleeping in because I'm hungover and I'm
not going to the gym and and I went hang
on what's going on because this is it
because I have my job as politician I'm
daddy you know I'm friend you know I'm
I'm I'm advocate and then you know the
book is it's a job right you know
selling a books a job full-time job I
need nine days a week in 36 hours a day
to do it and so I had them it may that's
one of the reasons why I decided to do
the body building things I'm like what
you can't drink and it'll be right till
November because I need that so I'm
trying to figure out if my brain is
looking for a new habit because I was
diagnosed before as like anti addictive
if that's even a real thing but I had a
doctor tell me one she's like you're
pretty much an anti addictive
personality like you won't get addicted
to stuff
and nari was addicted to oxy cotton even
though it's a physical thing more than a
mental thing but I still wouldn't trust
me with a pill right now yeah anyway I
think that we go way off track but I
just again and I don't know what your
therapist is - gonna tell you I'm gonna
tell you what jockle would tell you
though these little things are things
that you I know you know how to do them
you've done them your whole career in
the military you are watching a
crossroad and I know that might sound
exciting to people that are out there
that are thinking how crazy that must be
no there's times where Jodie was walking
watching a crossroad and there was
nothing going on for four days yeah and
he was watching that crossroad and so
you have that in you yeah you just got
to tell yourself that you know what this
stuff now this is what matters and how
you gonna tell yourself that this is
what matters it's because this is how it
connects to the strategic picture you
can't say that this matters because of
what it is right in front of me just
like when you're looking at the
crossroads
you're not thinking oh this crossroads
is important because the crossroads is
important know the car the reason it's
important is because you are supporting
keeping guys alive which is gonna help a
mission out which is gonna help the the
overall strategy wind commander's intent
the commander's intent the whole night
on the commander now you are just and
also what's your long-term mission and
that's what I kind of you just said it
yourself like oh I picked bodybuilding
because I there you just gave yourself a
mission right so what's your
administrative mission you know Echo's
made some big advances lately cuz he
started freakin reading books nice and
he wasn't doing that before but he he
got the long term mission of look you
know what I'm gonna learn as much as I
possibly can so you got a long-term
mission with your constituents right to
be the best city councilman and
represent so when they ask you a
question you're like boom that's kind of
the core psycho stuff that I would say
is like if anybody ever asked me a
question like when I was going to
college I if it asked me any question
about anything reading I'm gonna know it
that's just a bizarre P what's that OCD
thing to be like I'm gonna know
everything so but you have four kids you
train every day you get up at 4:00 in
the morning I gotta get it before we
sorry to riff on you guys on that man
like I know you wanted to do the
questions but when that guy when that
like the the first question was easy cuz
I'm like I'll just talk about what I
used to do and that one was like well if
I was to try and answer right now I'd be
lying I'd be a liar and I can't I I have
my moments still don't get me wrong
I'll have moments where I'm like this
has to get done and I'll fire through
this speech or all I'll write a report
or whatever it is and then and then I
lose it and it's like it's gone and
that's actually reinforcing what I just
said so when you have a near-term
mission that you know what the outcome
you know what the result is you know at
the end state is you know if the
commander's intent is like hey you got a
speech in two days okay now it's in one
day you can sit down and concentrate and
get it done which where you've missed
the connection now is the connection
between these menial tasks that don't
mean anything and how can I put them to
a long-term strategic goal and one of
those long-term strategic goals you can
put into place if nothing else is I'm
gonna discipline my mind to do these
menial tasks like a soldier and that's
pretty cool yeah a t-shirt Thank You
Jocko but whoever asked that question
thank you for asking it although I went
off and talked about me for the Moses
speaking attendance echoes gonna take a
little further that's not attention it's
what you said how you said that's what a
soldier does so that's like a little
exercising and I did this before I did
this in a couple of times okay like one
was how I quit drinking was I figured
out and you can do this with your diet
as well I figured out that basically
through all the stuff that I read that
you're wanting to eat junk food or drink
or whatever is your brain tricking you
because it's built to it's evolved for a
certain environment that environment
doesn't work isn't around I amor yeah
yeah so now we're an environment of
abundance that has to do dopamine anyway
Kim the conclusion that it's your brain
falling for a trick your physiology of
your brain falling for a trick makes you
want this stuff how he says how aqua
says that's not what a soldier would do
I had it in my mind I'm not gonna fall
for that trick I'm not a sucker that's
not you know doing this is what suckers
do
I'm not a sucker this is it's just like
self talking to yourself so I
essentially shamed myself out of
drinking yeah
just like he's doing the basically the
inverse into focusing you know I just
remember like I would I'm the guy that
we in Kosovo I quit smoking in a day
because I couldn't run up the hill next
to our camp
I said well obviously these things
aren't good anymore
mm-hm and I'd literally just I just I
even had a pack of my pocket for like a
week I just like you know yeah okay
throw those that I want that guy back
and I'm in search
I think it's been 10 years since I was
wounded I think I'm gonna find him again
probably on the stage for this
bodybuilding thing or something but yeah
I just I just couldn't answer that
question without talking about that
because I wouldn't have been truthful at
this point in my life and that's what's
cool is maybe that question right there
well something that isn't just forcing
you to face that I mean you might have
had it the back of your mind but now
you're going you know what I can't
answer that honestly because I'm not
there right now I'm not but I'm gonna
get back there real quick my moments so
stand by people stand by soldiers coming
back online
reboot jodi 3.0